ich muss 24 stunden lang in dieser
klasse ab hang und alles damit machen
das heißt wirklich alles alles versuchen
sie jetzt sagt ok rumlaufen wird nichts
rumhüpfen wohl eher oder robben auf dem
boden alte die musste ich innerhalb der
14 stunden sogar fortbewegen krank oder
gehe ich denke einfach ab würde auch für
wirtschafts wirklich immer wieder also
zu schocken wird
[Musik]
das gerade gesehen der war so kurz
rebecca in tschechien wie es nie war ich
so komplett interessiert sich bei dem
allergrößten müll dabei wird der blick
er war kurz der blick wo man erkannt hat
okay in dem moment hatte becker wegen
sich gedacht was maria gerade geld volle
kanne würde jemand gesehen ja aber ich
weiß es ist absolut spiel hat aber erst
so richtig gut monetarisiert ich bin für
mein geld wird ein altes ehepaar das
entgangen
[Musik]
also für mich ist das absolut noch mal
im urlaub
warum sagt sie so was sie sagt das so
als würde es diese überraschen
diese ganzen verein ich glaube die
entwickler von ribbeck aber ich habe
noch nicht so dieses sozialverhalten
programmiert kann das sein
in ihrer welt ist es scheinbar noch mal
mit flossen zu laufen ja das stimmt für
diverse kann ja also einerseits ist das
so komplett krank andererseits auch
wirklich bewunderung das so wenn ich
irgend so durchzieht das finde ich auch
und vor allem die hat ja an ich finde
dass man merkt ihr richtig die mit
motivation
das sagt richtig bock hinter ist
zumindest falls es nicht so sein sollte
kann ich es extrem authentisch spielen
und das ist glaube ich auch so des
erfolgs dinge dahinter weil die kids ihr
schauen denn ganz wirklich dass also das
was die merken das feuer drin und das
zeigen jetzt hier heute aus wenn man
sieht das dramatische musik unterlegen
einerseits muss man sagen okay rebecca
ringst nicht schon sehr motiviert
andererseits will man die aber auch
einfach helfen
du musst das nicht machen kein anderes
material
der name vom hotel kann sein damit die
anderen eben freundin können
das ist ja wissen konkurrenz zu wahren
dieses arme kind am hintergrund fürs
leben geschädigt familien oder gehst du
mit deinem vater auf einmal wenn wir
eine schule in meerjungfrauen kostüm die
gefäße politiker wollen das verrückte
ist ja auch guck mal die hat ja das
erste video schon in diesem hotel
gedreht und es gibt ja bestimmt auf die
sie einfach zwei tage später wo sie
dieses video gedreht bestimmen wie sie
in diesem verrückten künstlichen gesehen
habe oder was sie sich wohl denken diese
schleuse geschädigt läuft heute wenn der
video ob alex kanal wieder erster linie
der beschreibung dies zweimal darum
gelaufen ich muss erst mal wieder
hereinkommen kommentare geschrieben
nicht besser im wasser bewegen kann
aber was man ja auch schon zu sagen muss
jemand der so richtig tipps in die
kommentare war der muss noch älter sein
als affront denn der muss zwei gehen und
seine zum videoschauen eine zum darüber
nachdenken was gerade passiert und so
vielleicht war es auch die
meerjungfrauen und da sind ja auch in
dem hotel siebenjährige besser
hinkriegen hat ja im letzten video
gesagt so gewaltig dass sie gesagt also
dass auch andere meerjungfrauen was in
welchen medien lebst du manche von ihren
zuschauern machen vielleicht ist es ja
wirklich so das können wir gar nicht
wissen es kann ja sein dass wirklich
zuschauer ihr schreiben becky kannst du
bitte mal eine tagein meerjungfrau sein
so machen ich finde das ist echt
wirklich anstrengend und gar nicht so
einfach aussprechen kann man ernst
respekt an den kameramann der vor allem
früher wo ich auch noch nicht so gut
schwimmen konnte bin ich auch immer
einen teil nur so hier bei den treppen
gesprungen
warum nichts mehr trinken ja ja klar wir
hatten ja bei mir auch schon die theorie
aufgestellt dass becky gar nicht
schwimmen kann
we talk mit der die frau ist einfach
komplett hängen geblieben ist von der
beschreibung das hat so alles so das
management verfassen
auch becky wir haben nochmals vergessen
schreibt auch mal unten drunter dass
deine videos nicht ohne seine
genehmigung verwendet werden dürfen
dann kam mal dieser satz bei raus meine
inhalte aus meinem video auf diesem
kanal dann auch direkt weiterhin
verwenden jetzt ist leider glaube jetzt
ist der sommer schon im ersten
also der zug ist abgefahren ich habe
[Gelächter]
fertig machen ich bin also jetzt
verloren gegangene schwester für diese
nicht
ob noch etwas nettes zu sagen also ihre
schwimmtechniken hatte finde ich schon
mal besser also sieht nicht mehr nach
trinken kampf aus
[Musik]
der beste was wir sagen ja also im
vergleich zur ersten video meine dolby
gut gemacht ist da ist eine gewisse
steigerung da ja das ist für mich so
viel geld würdest du sowas machen viel
geld ich mir auch irgendwann werden auch
2010 oder youtube ein haben mir nicht
rein auf keinen fall auf gar keinen fall
[Musik]
dieses jahr ein zu wasser geschafft ich
war hier sicher wir haben aufpassen sie
wollen die leute da draußen für haben
weil sie sich über nacht bleiben geht ja
gar nicht
red wing war 24 stunden im pool für
einen tag der versuch etwas zu faken sie
sagt selbst wir ja ich wollte schon
impuls schön aber der bademeister mich
rausgeschmissen was ist mit dir du
redest die ganze zeit so als würden mehr
frauen wirklich existieren ist nicht der
fall also sollte ich will dich deine
phantasie zerstören aber es gibt keine
wellen worden
du zerstörst wäre die träume von ganz
vielen jungen kids aber die toppits die
einnahmen vom glauben schaue ich mir
wenn vor mir noch mal soll der so hatten
es gibt mir wieder vor der ganzen welt
schon anstrengend ist vor allem sie
kenne dieses zimmer er die lampen sind
zwar an aber das ist es nicht das des
tages es ist wahrscheinlich mittags 13
uhr so jetzt schlafen auf keinen fall
ist die nächste szene direkt danach
gefilmt nein nein die hat nicht in
diesen dingen geschlafen safe nicht safe
state aid mich und es richtig war sich
an den polen richtig spaß gemacht obwohl
ich war ich war zeuge nicht freundlich
ist das ist für mich kein ich dann zu
schauen so läuft wie so ein hotel musste
sofort ja ich weiß also wenn ich jetzt
in urlaub fahren und nichts ahnen
plötzlich sondern erwachsene frau dann
trifft diese eine menge vorfreude an hat
damit durch die lobby vom hotel springt
da welche auch denken wo wir hier wieder
das macht also aber für sie wissen doch
sie hat auch gesagt dass bei ihr ist das
ist nicht gehört
sie feiert trotzdem weiße und dafür
liebe ich sie auch irgendwie ich hab nur
ja man wird dann machen wir doch mal
kurz richtig spaß gemacht obwohl es
weder peinlich war vor den leuten damit
rumzuhüpfen
obwohl komische kommentare kamen die
loslachen oder heimlich ihr handy
gezückt haben die leute die so heute gut
aber das ist ja auch eine art natürliche
meint ihre reaktion oder das ist wie
wenn du halt irgendwie in der
touristenstadt bist und da irgendein typ
auf der straße
kegeln schockiert wie hier in köln an
jeder ampel manche film das ja gar nicht
so heimlich war es wieder auffällig und
meine verletzung in meiner hand tut ja
ein wenig weh
das bin ich mal gespannt auf das
angezeigt wird arno becker aber bei
hatte aber bei ja sozusagen muss es
falsch retten
ich bin mal gespannt ob das aber das war
schon was ich über das umladen der hat
ja einen kanal blog hier ist meinte ja
das wäre doch ein netter kommentar
gewesen ich wollte doch nur einfach gute
besserung sharma baby gut gewesen
wegen deinen finger ja ich würde sagen
wir nehmen jetzt so langsam mal
vorschläge auf in welche
nervenheilanstalt die bäckerin
teilweisen sollen wir hier eine gute
kennen leute einfach mal mit adresse
kommentieren oder allgemeinen tipps dazu
wie wir mit der lage umgehen sollten
würde alex ist wie gesagt auch verlinkt
leute erst eine chance sein video was
wir auch zusammen auf seinem comeback
gemacht haben wir zeigen ja wie waffen
wir uns jetzt rein von dieser schande
ich freu mich vor noch ein paar mehr wie
es jetzt für euch